and this is that story
my name is emily jacobson and this all
started in august of 2020.
one day in my apartment i was reading an
article about the new ratatouille ride
coming to disney world
and that sort of got the movie in my
head so afterwards when i was cleaning
up my apartment
i just started singing this song to
myself about the main character of the
movie remy
remy the ratatouille
the rat of all my dreams
and i found the song pretty funny and
decided to make a tick tock out of it
and when i recorded the song i sped it
up so my voice sounded a little more
cartoon-like
and i posted it on tick tock sent it off
to family and friends
and pretty much forgot about it it was
just for a joke a quick laugh
fast forward two months later i woke up
one morning to
hundreds of notifications it turned out
that
tick-tock superstar brittany broski had
posted a video
and on one side it was the characters
from the ratatouille movie
dancing and on the other side she was
dancing along with them
the background music was my little joke
song from
august and suddenly there were all these
people
flooding over to my video and liking
commenting
tagging their friends every day there
were thousands of people
using my song in their own videos and
that kind of exposure caught the
attention
of daniel mertzlaft who was a composer
arranger
overall musical genius my name is daniel
mertzluft i'm a working composer
arranger and when all of this stuff was
shut down
because of kovid i think me like every
other person
was longing for theater in some way i
became aware of emily's video when a
friend of mine
who also went viral on tick tock for his
song i'm an accountant
tagged me in the comments and said is
this the next grocery store musical
which was my big musical video that went
viral over the summer
so i listened to emily's video i thought
it was funny thought it was charming and
said
maybe
we have lots of strings french horn lots
of percussion we have the tubular bells
and glockenspiel and all of that to
bring us into the world
and it was in that moment that the
ratatouille
musical movement was born so suddenly at
that point
every single video on my for you page
was about the ratatouille musical
if you want to make it in the kitchen
yes ma'am don't waste your whiskers on
[Music]
dreaming
for a while i was kind of afraid that i
was going to get some sort of
legal notice or cease and desist but
then suddenly
people from the disney world started
joining in pat and oswald the voice of
remy he was tagging the director of the
movie brad bird who was chiming in
and then all of a sudden disney popped
up on their disney parks tick tock
account with a video they called the
unofficial audition
for the ratatouille musical the next day
pixar on instagram
was posting a picture of remy and
capturing it with my lyrics
so there were suddenly all these nods
here and there that made me think
all right disney's not necessarily mad
about this
this could be a good thing we've both
had multiple interviews a day
people asking me what my next projects
are record labels wondering if i have
things that i'm working on
managers agents um if disney were to
kind of bring this to fruition in some
way
they're kind of in a weird position i
don't think there's ever been
a situation where really the community
at large
has taken such a role in creating a
product
there would be a lot of demand i think
to use some of what has been created and
contributed on tick tock
if we've learned anything from the movie
i think it's that great art can come
from anywhere
and that's what has happened on tick
tock with the ratatouille musical
[Music]
you're